but I'll tell you what why don't we do
one more quick segment on this this year
alien thing
yeah let's yeah I really want to get
some aliens so uh how's it going
everybody aliens are real and we know it
no okay I don't know if they're real or
not I need some proof the Pentagon has
released those videos mm-hmm everyone's
talking about it's been I think like a
week and a half now yeah we did a
segment on it but those videos are old
men I know there are videos from 2007 I
know and Tom DeLonge blink-182 already
released a more formally I don't believe
me - okay but check out this story from
futurism Japan is creating protocols for
dealing with UFOs what you gonna do you
gonna shoot him what do you do well I'll
just read it I know they say in response
to the US Navy releasing its footage of
UFOs the Japanese government is now
preparing for how it would handle
student counter the Japanese Defense
Ministry says its pilots have never
encountered an unidentified flying
object
the Japan Times reports but authorities
want to be prepared should it happen in
the future and while the new protocols
are geared toward identifying military
drones they could also serve as guidance
for first contact with hypothetical
aliens either different from regular
aliens hypothetical aliens yeah well
because they can't say real aliens but
that's what it would be for no no it
could be military tech sure a lot of
people pointed this out when I was on
the Rogan podcast and I said don't you
think it's more likely that the UFOs are
US military yeah and he said like the
u.s. motion doesn't have this right so
there was like some snarky jokes where
like Joe Rogan going alien 'he's
because it like it a lot of people think
it makes more sense it's just US
military tech and not aliens I'm
inclined to agree with you on those but
Joe made the argument like no no could
be aliens and people are like aliens you
know the heem aliens the aliens guy
ancient aliens of course somebody
commented they were like Tim Poole drove
3,000 miles to be taught to be educated
on ancient aliens by Joe Rogan I thought
it was fun man it was a good
conversation it was fun here's our they
say identified flying objects right now
whenever an unknown aircraft enters
Japanese airspace fighter jets are
dispatched to identify where it came
from and if necessary force it to land
by firing warning shots Japan Times
report
but because military leaders don't know
whether that would work on a UFO or even
it would be - even if it would be
detectable bot from the ground new
guidelines could prove necessary quote
to be honest I don't believe in UFOs
well hold on let me stop you there
defense minister taro kono they exist we
know they exist the Pentagon has now
confirmed it several independent
organizations have confirmed it I'm not
saying they're aliens well an
unidentified flying object was confirmed
yes
whether I believe in him whether or not
it was no I'm referring to the original
video though it's like they just can the
Pentagon just said yeah yeah those those
videos are real they never said those
are aliens I didn't say there were
aliens he's I ain't saying no why are
you bringing up because he said I don't
believe in UFOs right we just saw videos
of UFOs well how do you say you don't
believe in a UFO because a UFO is an
unidentified laying he's wrong right
weird we know they exist he said but
because the Defense Department released
such a video I would like to hear from
the US side about its intentions and
analysis that's the point he's claiming
I don't believe in them even with the
videos being released and rent that's
ridiculous
it's not even just the Pentagon putting
out the videos or confirming them it's
several other organizations doing the
research saying we've seen these videos
it's several Navy naval pilots being
like yo this happened so we're gonna do
going to say all these you know
honorable servicemen and women are just
making things up and the videos were
fabricated gal get outta here man
conspiracies they say the new protocols
are based around a scenario in which a
pilot on a training or surveillance
mission encounters a UFO mid-flight if
UFOs are encountered training will be
canceled immediately a source within
Japan's air force told The Japan Times
we will seek to identify it from a safe
distance
including whether it is a drone and
report to the air defense Direction
center for orders so I believe that's
the gist of what their plan is so what
should we do if there are UFOs well I
mean what they used to do is go fly over
there and pop warning shots at them be
like land I think that's a terrible idea
if it is an alien because if it's an
alien they're like oh let's check this
planet out mmm oh this look at that
beautiful mountain mount I think it's
Mount Fuji if our our computers are
telling us it's Mount Fuji yeah
wonderful
shots get fired they're like whoa we're
being attacked labor so I was good now I
was reading some Italian ISM you know
cuz a lot of people you know we I think
was a good conversation I had with Joe
on UFOs but we didn't we didn't get
everything we possibly could have okay
and you know a lot of what people don't
seem to understand is that the we and
the prime or flies everything okay we as
humans know what a warning shot is
exactly does a centipede know so what if
what if they came here what the aliens
have no concept of war mm-hmm and so all
of a sudden we're seeing that these
things are flying at them and they're
just like what is happening we don't we
don't understand this this is just a
threat to us you know I mean or it's
like oh look it's a bug you know I mean
there's there's so much we don't we
assume about aliens okay what if what so
our emotions are based on the fact that
we evolved the way we did right we love
our children we love small things with
big eyes bugs don't feel that way bugs
lay a bunch of eggs and then you know
buzz off or in Soma yeah hamsters eat
their babies so even mammals are doing
messed-up stuff what if what if these
aliens are more like you know giant bugs
very smart giant bugs they lay a million
eggs the eggs hatch and they don't care
for them they feel nothing towards them
they don't have that emotion they
wouldn't understand our concept of love
and protection it's actually ever you
ever read Ender's Game or see the movie
yeah like the alien was a hive he didn't
understand the concept of individuality
right so it thought it was just like
akin to cutting hair when I was blowing
us up right same thing could happen here
not only that like they might not have
no company they might have no concept of
a warning shot so when we shoot at them
they're like they've declared war on us
you know they've expressed hostile
intentions mm-hmm time to go not even
yeah right and then they're like let's
just press this button and compress
space-time around this entire base and
the whole thing is vapor this entire
planet you know I was talking about this
earlier I think I don't if I was talking
with you about it about I was watching
Star Wars was I talking about that about
propulsion and stuff a little bit yeah I
think you're talking to Ian about it I
was watching Star Wars and the ships
they fly all have propulsion
there's jets in the back shooting out
some fishing them forward and I was like
why do we assume that that's archaic
technology yeah
we've seen videos of UFOs that they
clearly don't have some kind of
propulsion coming at the back they just
move so would it make more sense that
they're manipulating space to travel
very quickly and then if that's the case
wouldn't defensive shields just be
ripples in space like compression of
space-time yeah we rely using gravity in
some sort like a magnet kind of like
pushing anybody pull string and pulling
you know gravity to push you along so
like the the I guess the general warp
idea mm-hmm I don't wanna call it theory
I don't know if it's a theory or
whatever but it's like you compress
space-time in front of you and expand it
behind you and then you move through
space as opposed to like being within it
yeah so then you could theoretically go
faster than light or whatever but you're
trying to say we always have these
fictional depictions of aliens based on
technology from the 1950s rocketry yeah
it's like do you think if something was
able to travel across you know yeah yeah
they would be using something we
developed 70 years ago like we don't
even we don't even know of like I mean
we're still using that I think it's
archaic we just I don't know not maybe
it's not possible but I think it would
makes more sense for everything we need
in order to survive is to be able to
manipulate the fabric of space-time I
don't know that that's maybe a tall
order I get it right yeah but then I was
thinking about how would you shoot a
bullet at a UFO that could manipulate
space it could literally just blink and
be in a different position or the bullet
would actually go to it but that's
because space-time is warped or
compressed the bullet would just to us
look like it goes through it or around
it or around it you wouldn't even able
to see it or just simply disappear yeah
depending on how they manipulate space
mm-hmm I would imagine based on the way
they've described how these UFOs move
they're manipulating space in some
capacity or something like that hmm so
what do you think they're doing do you
hold on that I mean let me just ask you
know do you think aliens exist yes cool
of course they do okay
I mean and I say if in the fact that
they're flying around not here okay
absolutely not all right there's there's
there's I mean it's possible mm-hmm like
one of the things we talked about on the
Rogan podcast is what if we're like ants
to them and so like we don't care at the
anthill it's like we don't even pay pay
pay mind to it right and he was you know
Joe was saying like no way man they're
like you know they're looking at our
planet
seeing these like crude attempts at
traveling off planet the probably
interested in it just like wheat we
study ants yeah we do not everybody
cares what some people study right so if
we really were like ants and this is a
good point perhaps the aliens that are
coming are just like the the
entomologists of the alien race right
there they're like ooh let's go look at
these little ant critters and see what
they're up to
there was an interesting theory that we
talked about last week about it being
humans from the future
yeah going back we mentioned earlier
history yep yeah it was interesting and
the reason into that and the reason why
we don't they're not as prominent as
they were you know past is because in
the future they know it's a cell phone
era and so they're like oh you can't go
to this time period because the cell
phone period and right right
but they can travel back in time to you
know the 50s 60s see you know rocketry
war and all the stuff you think you
think crop circles are all just just a
hoax
probably just artists you know I mean
Nazca lines are crazy the Nazca lines
actually about the Nazca lines it's like
it's almost like they knew something was
out in space looking down at them and
they're like oh look look at the animals
that we have here the vibe I get it's
you know because what were they doing
that for did you see the rogen episode
where the dude said the Sphinx was
actually like from 9000 BC I haven't
seen the episode but I know about the
Sphinx yeah being much older than we
thought you're older yeah I also briefly
mentioned this on the road on the
rodents podcast and because it's like we
don't really know exactly we don't know
our own history yeah a lot of that's why
that's why I brought off the V I brought
up the Venus yeah I know you're pseudo
theory yeah yeah it's not my idea I know
I didn't know that was that's already
established yeah yeah like I didn't make
this up like so flows aren't familiar
it's the ideas I'm a little sad the
there's like I want to call it a theory
whatever you wanna call it but it's like
an idea very sure yeah well theory
because it it tends to be established in
some capacity but the idea is that Venus
was once was once a planet much like
Earth and a runaway greenhouse effect
started destroying the atmosphere in the
environment much like they're saying
we're doing now so us I don't say us but
like governmental forces we us let's
Venus you our governmental powers of
some sort created a giant vessel
get off the terraforming colonize earth
which was barren and empty and then they
terraformed it and then the ark the ship
took the DNA of every possible and well
they could so two of every animal story
the great flood yes global warming
flooded their planet destroyed it the
greenness effect wiped everything out so
they got in the big ship flew away but
very few people actually survived so
what ends up happening is you have this
newly terraformed earth barely
terraformed you immediately drop all
this potential new life that's growing
and adapting and evolving over tens of
thousands of years so it's not
completely identical to the life that
was another planet and then the few
humans that are now on this planet have
no access to technology they have no
access to the previous world most of
them like an insurance salesman has no
idea how to smelt or yeah so then he has
kids those kids have never experienced
life in a technological advanced society
so they they create a book saying like
here's why here's what you got to do and
here's why you got to do it yeah two or
three generations go by it's magic yep
no one knows anymore and so it's awfully
familiar like we're on a planet it's
kind of runaway right now I mean on musk
is building his Mars ship you um musk is
like we got a list Mars that's what I
was saying - EFT - Joe it's like you go
to Mars you have 20 families they all
know what Earth is like they have kids
the kids don't you know then those kids
have kids and Earth is just a fantasy to
them you know it's like a dot in the sky
they've never seen I've never been to
40,000 years later they're gonna be
alike Earth is we send a satellite to
earth and it was just acid rain and
destroyed the satellite there's nothing
there yeah it's just a wasteland we live
on Mars Venus 2.0 yup yep but I guess
we'll find out eventually perhaps what's
gonna happen this is the the these are
all like joke theories is that we're
being buttered up you know they're
getting us ready Liam's cuz look now
that the Pentagon has said yes these
videos are real what comes next is a
sighting and then there's a story it's
like this person claims have seen a UFO
just like the Pentagon described mm-hmm
then six months go by and it's three or
four sightings six months go by and it's
like oh wow there were like 12 or 30
yeah then all of a sudden there's a
there's a ship floating over New York
for a few minutes then leaving and then
everyone's seen it and they're like
these things keep appearing what are
they
they bought us up so that when they
finally do first contact it's like
that's what the aliens were doing
because if they just did it right now
people be like aliens would we do shoot
him run died no I I guess I have more
faith in people
I feel like they'd be like yeah but
we're not really that simple
yeah mm-hmm nope Trump would Trump would
come out and he'd be like we are very
grateful to announce aliens have made
first contact and I am going to
personally meet them and we are going to
have a very peaceful very prosperous
relationship and then everyone the media
would be like trump is siding with the
enemy the aliens will kill us kill them
before they kill us people would go riot
it would be chaos war Trump would come
out and be like we must not trust the
aliens yeah their potential threat and
then every media would be like the
aliens are our friends trust them bend
the knee bow to them it's like you know
I'm not dude people would go nuts and it
would be it would be bedlam yeah
probably
yep all right yeah all right thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you